foreign
which is dimension reduction
and so if we remember in the subset
selection methods we were just taking a
subset of the predictors and using least
squares to fit the model and then in
Ridge regression on the lasso we were we
were really doing something different
where we were taking all of the
predictors but we weren't using least
squares we were using a shrinkage
approach to fit the model
and now we're going to do something
different which is we're going to use
least squares but we're not going to use
least squares on the original predictors
X1 through XP instead we're going to
come up with new predictors which are
linear combinations of the original
predictors and we're going to use these
new predictors to fit a linear model
using least squares
so this is known as Dimension reduction
and the reason it's called Dimension
reduction is because we're going to use
those P original predictors to fit a
model using M new predictors
where m is going to be less than P so
we're going to shrink the problem from
one of P predictors to one of M
predictors
so in a little bit of detail here we're
going to Define m linear combinations Z1
through z m where m is some number less
than p
and these are going to be linear
combinations of the original p
predictors
so for instance ZM is going to be the
sum of the P predictors where each
predictor is multiplied by Phi MJ where
vmj is some constant and in a minute
we'll talk about where this vmj comes
from
but the point is once we get our new
predictor is Z1 through z m we're just
going to fit a linear regression model
using least squares but instead of using
the X's we're going to use the Z's
so in this newly squares model my
predictors are going to be disease and
my coefficients are going to be Theta
naught through Theta m
and the idea is that if I can just be
really clever in how I choose these
linear combinations in particular if I'm
clever about how I choose these vmjs
then I can actually beat least squares
that I would have gotten if I had just
used the Raw predictors
so um one thing that we should notice is
that you know on the previous slide here
we had this this summation over Theta m
z i m
and if we look at that a little bit more
carefully and we plug in the definition
of Zim
which remember was just a linear
combination of the original X's
and we we switched to the order of the
sums and we do a little bit of algebra
we see that what we actually have here
is a sum over the p predictors
times this quantity
times the pth predictor
so this is actually just a linear
combination of the original X's
where
the linear combination involves a beta J
that's defined like this
so the point is that when I do this
Dimension reduction approach and I
Define these new Z's that are linear
combinations of the X's I'm actually
going to fit a linear model that's
linear in the original X's
but the linear the the beta JS in my
model need to take a very very specific
form
so so these Dimension reduction
approaches they're giving me models fit
by least squares but but I'm fitting the
model not on the original predictors
it's on a new set of predictors
and I can think of it actually as
ultimately a linear model on the
original predictors but using different
coefficients that kind of take this
funny form here so in a way it's sort of
similar to Ridge and lasso right it's
still least squares still a linear model
in all the variables but there's a
There's a constraint on the coefficients
that's exactly right but we're getting a
constraint in a different way we're not
getting a constraint like in the ridge
Case by saying okay my sum of squared
beta is needs to be small instead we're
saying my betas need to take this really
funny form if you look at it but it's
got a simple interpretation in terms of
least squares on a new set of features
so and the the idea here is really it
boils down to the bias variance
trade-off by saying that my betas need
to take this particular form I can win
um I can get a model with low bias and
also low variance relative to what I
would have gotten if I had just done
plain vanilla Lee squares on the
original features
um one thing that I should mention is
that this is only going to work nicely
if m is less than p and instead if my M
equaled p
then I would just end up with least
squares and this whole dimension
reduction thing would have just given me
least squares on the raw data